Speaker 1: Let's go next to our friend Eric
from Cancun.
We tried talking to Eric last week after months
off and his connection just didn't work.
We couldn't hear him.
Eric, are you with us today?
Speaker 2: I mean, as you can see, I put next
to my name the topic I want to talk about
and to mention about.
I also will ask you if you heard the sound
from Eminem.
Speaker 1: Sorry if I've heard the song.
Stand By Eminem.
I have become familiar with the song, of course.
Speaker 2: And when is it that that song is
more like a musical?
Lizzie About the dangers of toxic fandom?
Because the song is the song was very angry
that Eminem didn't grow back because he is
a busy guy.
He should reflect that Eminem had a hard time
reaching back to every single thing.
And you also struggle with that.
Despite that, you have a dreadful name.
And is it the ego being that worrying that
toxic fandom will be filling a void within
them?
And also then it will be that they need something
to field themselves with.
Speaker 1: Well, Eric, you've really hold
on.
Let let's take it a piece at a time, because
what you're throwing out at me is so media
and substantive, I think you've identified
quite, quite a phenomenon, which I think exists.
There is definitely toxic fandom in the space
I inhabit, you know, on the Internet, podcasting,
YouTube.
And I think you couldn't be more right in
your analysis, a brilliant analysis that some
of these folks become toxic or obsessed in
their fandom through these parasocial relationships
because it is within them that they have a
void.
They are trying to fill that.
That's an excellent analysis, Eric.
Speaker 2: It's also them and rather see you
as a friend.
And it's nice though, because that would be
a healthier way to interact with celebrities.
And also so I have my personal agenda instead
of wanting to take over your life.
Speaker 1: And where did you say you see me
more more as a friend than a son?
Is that what you said?
Speaker 2: No.
I see you as a friend more than an idol.
Oh, because.
Because that would be a healthier way to interact
with celebrities.
And also so I take my own life and say, well,
then take over yours.
Speaker 1: Right?
Take control of your life, Eric.
I love it.
What a message of self-empowerment.
Speaker 2: Hello there.
I want to mention that these talks with my
would apply within relationships with hobbies
and with religion.
I will tell you why.
Again, religion made me want to go to the
churches and talk to the priest because they
want answers and solutions for their problems.
But Morgan Freeman, when he was guarding Bruce
Almighty, he said that they forget that they
have the power to fix it themselves.
So can't complain.
Also said that.
Eric, please.
Speaker 1: Eric, do you have a photographic
memory?
Speaker 2: And then maybe it's because of
my autism.
Hmm.
And then let me finish.
Sorry about what is in the piece.
I will be sold.
There is a guy named Joe Gardner convulsing
into the sewer.
And after afterlife he meets a guy named Morwell
winces.
Then when you are to obsess with a hobby or
a passion, you become a lost soul.
My way less obsessed with Tetris and in relationships
I should like called Steven Universe.
Steven wanted to marry his girl, Courtney,
but then Courtney said that she wants to finish
college first and was devastated.
So his stepmom, Garland, tells him that although
it's Steven, they like to be together, they
have individual lives.
And also that soul mate is a complement.
Another missing piece.
Whatever is missing in Steven's life.
Courtney cannot feel it.
He has to feel it himself.
Speaker 1: Eric, if I may, I have no idea
what you're talking about.
And that's okay because I could listen to
this stuff all day.
I really appreciate you calling in, Erik.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Well, I think I know so many quirky things
in the show, but I try to give the best context
I can.
So I think it would be better to carry out
or else I would be like, Bro, no, no, no,
no.
I would be like, Bro, no.
Speaker 1: Eric, thank you so much.
And stay safe, okay?
Speaker 2: So.
Speaker 1: All right.
There is Eric from Cancun.
While I am, I am exhausted from that.
That is really something that that
is
that
is extraordinary.